Hey Henry, can you bite my finger please?
Bite my finger
Henry, we're never gonna go viral unless you bite my finger!
Henry says, "Good morning Uncle Hank, it's Monday!"
Henry, do you know how I can tell you're an astronaut?
Like all astronauts, you're wearing space pyjamaaaaaas!
Henry, like his father, wears pyjamas until well into the afternoon
We both work from home
Henry, why are you so much better lit than I am? You're stealing my light
You seem to have forgotten that this YouTube channel is called 'vlogbrothers' not 'vlog-adorable-baby'
Having now spent 7 weeks with a newborn, I feel like I'm something of an expert in the field
and while babies could hardly be more adorable...
I can't help but come to the conclusion that babies can be a tiny bit self-centered
Did you just punch me in the face on purpose?
It's always 'change MY diaper, feed ME, offer ME comfort, give ME a pacifier'
What about my pacifier Hank? When will Henry give ME a pacifier?
In fact Hank, sometimes it doesn't even seem like Henry thinks I'm a person, it seems like he thinks I'm some kind of..
Robot-need-filler
*Robot voice* I am your robot-need-filler. What are your needs? Do you need to be nomed?
nom-nom-nom-nom-nom-nom
But anyway Hank, the weirdest part of the complete inability of infants to apprehend that other people also have needs
is that I don't care. Something weird and base and nurturing happened to me when he was born that caused me to wanna, like,
change poopy diapers
By the way Hank, no matter how efficient a diaper changer you are, there will always be one nanosecond between the old diaper and the new diaper where the bottom is diaperless
and to Henry, that moment is known as
poopy-time
There's something about being a parent that that turns you weirdly insular, so you find yourself really only caring about the needs of your kid
Which is why, for instance, I forgot to tell you guys that I had a book coming out in like 25 days
Henry says "'Will Greyson, Will Greyson  available for pre-order now! Link in the dooblydoo!"
Thanks bud, I appreciate the marketing
Hank there's this phrase in the study of religion, ultimate concern...
Your ultimate concern is the thing or value that you prize above all others, the one you would die for, the one you would kill for.
Now, of course it's pretty easy to go through life without an ultimate concern,
for instance, I don't think Henry has one yet,
You know, because he's still in the business of self-preservation
But Hank, nerdfighters, that's what I want this week's theme to be,
Do you have an ultimate concern? What is it? Should you have one?
Right now, my ultimate concern certainly involves making sure that this little guy is happy and healthy and
has an opportunity to look at himself in various mirrors
But I don't know if should be limited to that. Should your ultimate concern be limited to your family?
Should it be about politics? or policy? about your community or your nation? Or the human species?
Should it take into account other species? And if so, should those species be treated as equal to humans?
Or should self-preservation and our own needs trump everything?
and when did my husky voice transform into the voice of a pubescent boy?
Those are my non-rhetorical questions of the week, I'll see you on Wednesday
*henry sighs*
Ugh,
Did you just sigh because you're bored of me video blogging?
Willie says "I'm still here! and I'm cute too!"
*John sings* How we gonna kick it, gonna kick it, tummy time
Yes Hank, Henry's favorite rap songs include 'how we gonna kick it, gonna kick it, tummy time',
'no sleep 'till burpin',
and of course ' who's down with opp? dad's down with opp'
you know,
other peoples poop..